c'est très symbolique quand on passe ce
portail pour les coupés du monde là
vraiment une réalité concrète des choses
pour fait de faire un projet là dessus
sont vraiment impliqués
c'est important de savoir ce qui s'est
passé avant que ça se reproduise on sera
plus qu ils ont vécu non pas les oublier
au final donc le titre à 2,2 cm duo 30
cm à droite
trois jours après leur retour de voyage
les élèves se retrouvent au cdi
ils ont une quarantaine de panneaux à
faire pour l'exposition qui d'ici un
mois sera présenté aux officiels et aux
parents d'élèves un une rigoureuse
restitution de leur travail sur le thème
des femmes dans la shoah marceline
loridan-ivens marcel dressler des récits
et des témoignages comme celui de
rosette les vies des rescapés deux fixes
qui l'ont rencontré à paris le 3 mars
rosette et son frère furent emmenés dans
des wagons à bestiaux en direction du
camp d'auschwitz-birkenau en pologne
à ce moment-là tous deux ne savait pas
où il allait les conditions dans
lesquelles les déportés voyage à étaient
inhumaines et on s'imagine mieux ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle a pu vivre sur
les lieux du drame
finalement parce qu'on
on peut se projeter enfin se projeter
entre guillemets et et voir vraiment ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle a pu endurer
pendant le voyage à auschwitz
on a vu avec un qui ont la visiter
l'endroit à birkenau ci et ça nous a
effectivement touché beaucoup parmi les
dizaines de milliers de victimes
disparues dans l'holocauste
annette zelman dénoncée par le père de
l'homme qu'elle aimait désapprouvant
leur mariage il avait souhaité un rappel
à l'ordre car le régime de vichy
interdisait les mariages mixtes avec une
personne juive
ça a conduit à son transfert je suis
c'est la jeune femme est morte deux
jours plus tard donc elles étaient gazés
immédiatement
ça nous a beaucoup touchés parce que on
a pu voir que ça pouvait réellement
briser des familles les conséquences et
cette dénonciation ont dépassé
considérablement le souhait d'
éloignement du délateur en effet rongé
par la culpabilité
hubert a contacté l'ambassadeur scappini
ainsi que des amis haut placés pour
tenter de réparer son erreur
en vain saluant là mais ne marque que
l'on qui ajuste encore deux-trois faire
et puis j'ai fait un super boulot
les élèves ont appris jusqu'où peuvent
mener l'antisémitisme le racisme le
rejet de la différence à eux d'en parler
maintenant avec tous les moyens de leur
général
après on peut rajouter des plombs et on
peut élargir en fonction de ce que kate
elle veille l'équipe de reportage
s'attelle au montage d'une vidéo qui
sera diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
florian il a pris les photos et anna
prix des vidéos et moi j'ai aussi pris
quelques photos et donc en tout on a à
peu près
mille photos et une centaine de vidéos
tels eh bien on met en lumière rouge
arrive à récupérer sur rue c'est
exceptionnel de pouvoir là-dessus
par qui on veut et ça m'a un peu aussi
la pression parce qu'il faut que ce soit
quelque chose de très bonne qualité mais
c'est déjà si les élèves adhèrent si
bien à la réussite du projet pédagogique
c'est peut-être aussi grâce aux livres
qu'ils ont lus et qu'ils les ont
familiarisé avec marceline loridan-ivens
ginette kolinka entre autres on dit le
panneau de marceline ginette enfin voilà
on les appelle par leur prénom comme si
nous avions connu en voilà et c'est
cette proximité je pense qu'il est très
important puisque les élèves se les
approprient voilà comme si c'était
l'histoire de leur grand mère ou de leur
arrière grand mère
selon un bilan du ministère de
l'intérieur après deux années de baisse
les actes antisémites ont bondi de 74%
des 1018 une situation très inquiétante
contre laquelle l'éducation a très
certainement un rôle à jouer
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont peu de
connaissances là dessus et je pense que
tous ces actes sont liées aussi à
beaucoup d'ignorance c'est important de
qu'on n'en parle que on ne se rendent
compte des choses commencent à hésiter
et et oui je pense que l'éducation peut
avoir un rôle contre ces actes
antisémites il
au cours de leur scolarité les élèves
sont censés rencontrer trois fois
l'histoire du génocide des juifs ancien
mme 2 en troisième et en première
[Musique]
quand
non